parents are being urged to look out for
the symptoms of strep a infection that
is after the deaths of at least six
children the UK Health Security Agency
says that investigations are underway
following reports of an increase in
cases well joining me now is Dr Simon
Clark he's a microbiologist from the
University of reading uh Dr Clark good
to see you again on Sky News good
morning could you just remind our
viewers please of what the symptoms are
to look out for so initially the the
symptoms that people need to look out
for are perhaps tiredness nausea the
sort of things that are clearly common
uh when you pick up an infection uh
within the next several hours
um of starting to develop a disease
um somebody will probably get a rash
they may have uh flushed cheeks a
swollen tongue really the only way
though of being sure that somebody has
got group a strep infection is to take a
swab from the back of their throat and
to culture it in a laboratory so these
initial signals while they're a good
indicator they're not free from people
should see their doctors
um the worrying thing for parents of
course is is to think that you know this
appears to be causing fatality uh will
be at very small numbers but higher at
higher incidents than what we've seen
pre-pandemic
um how does it result in in such a
tragic outcome
um well I think really there is every
chance or it's not been proven that uh
the the because children were not mixing
during during the pandemic we're not
mixing as much as they had been
previously that means that they weren't
able to generate an immunity to these
sorts of bacterial infections which are
common many people carry this bacteria
in their throats and it causes no
problems so what you end up with is a
situation where there is less Community
immunity to infection and more
transmission and therefore the infection
is that the bacteria is more able to
find people who are going to be
susceptible to it that's why you end up
in the situation perhaps
um that we have I should emphasize
though it's a reasonable hypothesis but
it hasn't been proven
is there anything I I suppose we're
speculating I don't suppose that you
know uh the details but is there
anything to link uh these these tragic
deaths of these children in terms of how
in terms of why it was fatal
um I am unaware of any reason why this
might have been in clusters
um I'm only unaware of any perhaps
underlying health conditions if we even
know about those of course uh no I I
don't think we fully understand why some
people are susceptible to this type of
infection incidentally you can make the
same argument about all sorts of other
bacterial infections that infect uh
children adults we don't understand what
makes individuals particularly
susceptible it might of course just be
bad luck
um what is the advice about sending
children to school because
um in children quite frequently go to
school with sore throats
yes and it's not unheard of to have
cases of uh um scarlet fever in in
schools and in universities as well
um but of course Public Health bodies
local authorities should be aware of
what's going on uh in those situations
and should be able to to offer the
appropriate advice it's also worth
stating that this infection is really
very easily treatable with antibiotics
so catch it early enough by that only
diagnose it early enough
um and and it should be imminently
treatable
and meanwhile
um parents are being advised to get
their children vaccinated against the
flu
um presumably that doesn't provide any
additional protection for this
particular illness no flu is a virus a
group a strep is a bacteria they're very
different entities
um but I think the the call to vaccinate
people against flu is because we're
seeing High numbers of flu cases in the
community and we know that children are
an engine of spread for that virus
and and finally there isn't a vaccine uh
is there for for strep a but um that
apparently they are looking into
developing one oh yeah these things I
mean this is just one of a long list of
uh infections that do the rounds where
we would like to have a vaccine but it
proves much more difficult
um
perhaps on the surface appears that it
ought to be
um we got very lucky with covid which is
of course still in people's minds
um but uh other things now it's far more
difficult far more tricky to to uh to
produce vaccines for them all right Dr
Simon Clark always good to get your
analysis on Sky News thank you you're
welcome